[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí américa este es
el magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
visitaremos méxico donde las autoridades
investigan otro posible feminicidio el
de luz raquel padilla la madre de un
niño autista que fue quemada viva en el
estado de jalisco su asesinato generó
protestas en contra del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador quienes
activistas consideran que no hace lo
suficiente para detener los feminicidios
en un país en el que en promedio 10
mujeres son asesinadas cada día
y vamos a perú porque una vez más el
presidente pedro castillo enfrenta al
fantasma de la destitución tras el
sorpresivo despido de su ministro del
interior mariano gonzález el funcionario
saliente lo acusó de corrupción y la
fiscalía inició una nueva investigación
en su contra despertando las voces del
impeachment dentro del poderoso congreso
peruano les explicamos
y vamos a panamá donde el presidente de
laurentino cortizo sigue tratando de
desmantelar la ola de protestas en su
contra y cuyos bloqueos tienen
paradójicamente bloqueado al país que
conecta a un océano con otro nos
llevamos a ver cómo viven los ciudadanos
aislados por los cortes de las vías
y vamos de inmediato a méxico porque hay
conmoción por el asesinato de luz raquel
padilla la madre de un niño autista que
fue quemada viva tras denunciar amenazas
es la más reciente víctima de la
violencia machista en el país
norteamericano justo cuando se conoció
que junio fue el mes más violento de
2022 para las mujeres con 89
feminicidios esta semana se conocieron
además detalles de la desaparición de de
vania escobar en abril en el norteño
estado de nuevo léon a una tercera
autopsia confirmó que en efecto se trató
de un feminicidio y que la joven fue
abusada sexualmente
el estado de nuevo léon es el cuarto del
país con más desaparecidos según cifras
oficiales más de seis mil activistas
trabajan sin descanso para encontrarlos
veamos el informe de nuestro equipo en
terreno
el río santa catarina suele pasar por
debajo de este puente en la ciudad
juárez ahora casi seco el lecho del río
es inspeccionado por un grupo de
voluntarios en búsqueda de rastros de
cuerpos o restos humanos estamos en una
época de sequía y si hay un lugar que
está más verde que el resto del espacio
puede decir que allá hay algo que se
está descomponiendo la razón por la cual
la búsqueda de hoy se lleva a cabo allí
es por los muchos casos de personas
desaparecidas en la zona todos estos
voluntarios han perdido a un ser querido
cercano este municipio pues tuvo una
alta incidencia en desapariciones
tenemos varios casos que son de esta
área entonces
tiene confluyen avenidas importantes
entonces es rápido bajar y aventar a
alguien no aventar un cuerpo aventar un
resto con recursos básicos los
familiares de las víctimas exploran
entre escombros y huesos de animales la
policía vela por su seguridad pero sin
participar directamente en la actividad
decepcionada por las autoridades porque
pues no nos dan apoyo y nosotros tenemos
que organizarnos que está buscando en
ocasiones si uno pierde las esperanzas
los ánimos se van hasta el suelo tienes
ganas de aventar la toalla de
de dejar todo pero y luego otra vez
empiezas otra vez con la esperanza de
encontrarlos
después de una década de relativa calma
las desapariciones de nuevo léon han
regresado dramáticamente 200 personas
han desaparecido desde principios de año
sandra acaba de asistir a la segunda
reunión con el juez encargado de la
investigación por la desaparición de su
hermana y su sobrina en septiembre de
2021 están muy espacios no vemos avances
ya no se mira avances de nada es ni nos
dan razones tampoco no se miran este el
empeño que tengan por su trabajo
la lucha de estas familias también es
legal lourdes perdió a su hijo hace 12
años hoy usa su experiencia para ayudar
a otros como sandra el camino que
llevamos los que tenemos muchos años y
el empuje que ya no tan fácil te pueden
cuente o luchas
o te mueres de la tristeza en ellos y
ellas esperan que nosotros sobre eso
desde 1964 más de 100 mil personas han
desaparecido en méxico principalmente a
causa del crimen organizado algunos de
los rostros de estos hombres y mujeres
están pintados en una plaza dedicada a
ellos en el corazón de la capital de
nuevo león monterrey
vamos a eeuu la comisión parlamentaria
que investiga el ataque al capitolio del
6 de enero de 2021 celebró una última
audiencia pública el jueves por la noche
antes del receso de verano en ella se
revelaron detalles de la acción o más
bien la inacción del entonces presidente
de donald trump para detener el ataque a
la democracia estadounidense a pesar del
llamado desesperado de varios
funcionarios de su administración se
espera que en otoño el comité entregue
su informe en el que podría emitir
recomendaciones penales al departamento
de justicia dejando en manos del fiscal
general eric harland la decisión de si
trump debería ser procesado
hemos confirmado en numerosas
entrevistas con altos líderes policiales
y militares con él presidente pensé su
personal y funcionarios del gobierno que
ninguno de ellos escuchó al presidente
de trump ese día no llamó para dar
órdenes no llamó para ofrecer asistencia
how the first stent y en perú revisamos
la cifra de la semana 7 ese es el número
de veces que el presidente pedro
castillo ha cambiado al ministro del
interior en menos de un año de mandato
el último mariano gonzález permaneció en
el cargo solamente dos semanas en su
lugar nombró a willy huerta pero la
polémica no para con los cambios en el
gabinete el funcionario saliente acusó
al presidente peruano de corrupción tras
su sorpresivo despido por lo cual la
fiscalía abrió una cuarta investigación
preliminar en contra del presidente
pedro castillo por un presunto delito
contra la administración de justicia y
encubrimiento personal lo que una vez
más revive el pulso de poder con el
congreso que estudia cómo invocar la
cuestión de confianza esto es el
mecanismo de la constitución peruana
para remover a un mandatario del cargo
en este caso en contra del castillo que
sería la tercera vez y con el poderoso
congreso peruano que ha hecho que haya
seis presidentes en cinco años castillo
podría ser sólo uno más en la lista una
crisis perpetua que les explicamos en el
siguiente informe de arianna villacorta
es la cuarta investigación preliminar
que la fiscalía de perú abre contra el
presidente pedro castillo esta vez por
presunto delito contra la administración
de justicia y encubrimiento personal
algo que el mandatario desestima
nosotros no tenemos tiempo para
entretenernos en otras cosas nosotros no
estamos acá para hacer un circo el país
nos ha puesto para trabajar por el perú
el martes el jefe de estado del país
inca destituyó por sorpresa mariano
gonzález ministro del interior durante
15 días horas después de su despido
acusó al mandatario de estar
comprometido con actos de corrupción y
obstruir la justicia esto porque según
gonzález su destitución se produjo luego
de autorizar el nombramiento de una
unidad policial especial destinada a
localizar y arrestar a los aliados del
presidente que estén bajo investigación
penal como el ex ministro de transportes
juan silva el ex secretario de palacio
bruno pacheco y un sobre el mandatario
fray vásquez lo que recibí
fue un reclamo natural
porque él es porque no estaba de acuerdo
con mi decisión
no es que me haya dicho el presiente en
algún momento no capturé a los prófugos
pero lo que me cuestionaba era la
decisión de ir por ellos
las otras tres investigaciones que
castillo tiene abiertas son una por
presuntos delitos de organización
criminal y tráfico de influencias en
torno a contrataciones ilícitas en el
ministerio de transporte y
comunicaciones otra por supuestas
irregularidades en ascensos en miembros
de las fuerzas armadas y de la policía y
otra en relación al presunto plagio de
su tesis doctoral
asimismo ha sobrevivido a dos intentos
de destitución y algunos legisladores
piden un tercer juicio político por las
nuevas acusaciones
nos vamos para panamá un país que tiene
la capacidad de unir el comercio mundial
a través de su canal que conecta el
océano pacífico con el atlántico y que
se encuentra bloqueado en buena parte de
su interior por cuenta de las protestas
antigubernamentales que el presidente de
laurentino cortizo no ha logrado
desactivar a pesar de varias concesiones
nuestro corresponsal oscar sulbarán nos
cuenta cómo están viviendo los panameños
que se encuentran aislados por los
cierres de las vías
robinson lleva varias horas de espera en
su camión en pacora una zona rural
ubicada a 40 km del centro de la capital
el paso por donde se dirige a entregar
gasolina está bloqueado por las
protestas desde hace dos semanas en sus
15 años como camionero no recuerda haber
vivido una situación similar pero la
prueba no te culpa de nadie puede nadie
que no echemos la culpa a nadie ya le
digo yo estoy totalmente de acuerdo de
lo que está pasando
porque necesita muerte
sube el gobierno y baja el gobierno y es
la misma cosa
entre ellos todo está bien entre el
humilde acabado lo que decimos otros
personas de la clase menos el gas de
media es lo que nos perjudica entretanto
a 300 metros hacia donde robinson se ha
quedado bloqueado
alexis noguera ha optado por ser
carretillero para transportar productos
de un lado al otro cuando iniciaron las
protestas trabajaba en una ferretería
pero al perder ventas por el cierre de
vías quedó desempleado
la gente quiere que se acaben porque
también quieren trabajar yo también
quiero trabajar hoy para ahorita mismo
todavía carretilla no parece tanto algo
mal mi tío
y eso
pero trabajar y seguir adelante lejos de
los rascacielos citadinos kevin sánchez
junto a otros indígenas no me google
mantienen el bloqueo como parte de las
protestas en todo el país aunque a
varios de ellos les ha costado su empleo
no renunciarán a la manifestación de
calle con nuestra responsabilidad lo
pudimos dejar a un lado nuestras
familias no podemos dejarnos a un lado y
vinimos a luchar en la calle defender a
los pueblos panameño que hoy ellos lo
están viendo otro punto de vista que la
manifestación han afectado a ellos que
estamos creando un problema pero el
objetivo de esto es que ellos al final
van a ser beneficiados si hay una
respuesta positiva aunque
momentáneamente se flexibilizan los
cierres para dar paso a personal médico
y productos como alimentos o medicinas
se estima que hasta ahora estos bloqueos
que se repiten en al menos 10 puntos a
lo largo de todo el país han causado
pérdidas económicas que superan los 500
millones de dólares
y en la vecina colombia se instaló el
nuevo congreso con una inédita mayoría
de fuerzas de centroizquierda lo que le
permitiría al presidente electo gustavo
petro sacar adelante su ambicioso
programa de reformas los legisladores
que fueron elegidos en marzo por un
período de cuatro años es decir hasta
2026 ocuparon sus sillas en una
ceremonia encabezada por el mandatario y
wang duque quien dejará el cargo el 7 de
agosto con una desaprobación del 65 por
ciento según la más reciente medición de
la firma invamer durante la sesión el
presidente saliente entregó un balance
de los que considera fueron sus logros
durante los últimos cuatro años un
discurso que la mayoría de colombianos
catálogo de desconectado de la realidad
y que de hecho lo llevó a ser
interrumpido por abucheos en varias
oportunidades el nuevo congreso tiene
mayor participación de mujeres con un 29
por ciento con respecto al 20 por ciento
de la anterior y un número récord de
representantes de la comunidad el gmt y
kumar
[Aplausos]
gracias por acompañarme en aquí américa
en la producción estuvo a giovanni
agudelo pueden ver esta emisión y las
anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom por favor enviarme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla y para
más información de nuestro continente
sigan viendo france24
[Música]